but once you're at like a b almost a B2
level uh do you do anything special to
maintain them
but I would say I would say so but you
know there there are languages like uh
German that I reached C1
um I I don't think I've reached C2 in
German just because like I haven't
really needed it so you know just prefer
to focus on different languages and try
to get to B2
uh so I go through phases in which I
just neglect uh determine and I don't
get a lot of exposure so I I do try to
get some exposure and eventually you
know if I'm doing videos in the streets
of parents and I meet German people so
I'll talk to them right and I I know I
may interview them uh so it's just like
a nice way to just try to you know keep
it going